hi I'm from Drexel University
um this talk is about the paper strategy
proof scheduling with predictions this
is a joined work with Eric balkanski and
my advisor vaselis Gonzalez
so in this work we're focusing on the
tension between algorithms with worst
case guarantees and machine learning
based heuristics on one side the
algorithms with worst case
um performance framework offers really
about robust divorce case guarantees
however
um these guarantees are often defined by
our single worst instance and sometimes
they could be all really pessimistic and
does not capture what is actually
happening in practice on the other side
we have these machine learning based
heuristics which works very well in
practice but most of them do not admit
any non-trivial worst case guarantees
um there might be instance that really
breaks them
this recent line of work called learning
augmented algorithm or algorithm design
work predictions aims to resolve this
tension by designing algorithms
augmented with machine learning
predictions were advice ideally this
algorithm aims to achieve really good
much better performance when the given
predictions are correct and still
maintaining the worst case guarantee
when the predictions are are arbitrarily
wrong
so just to provide some extra background
on the algorithm design with the
prediction framework
um there has been more than 120 papers
published on this with this framework
um in the past four years and you can
see uh the link I provided for the full
list and check out all the works
um but in general the framework focusing
on algorithms that are augmented with
predictions or advice about the instance
and there's no assumption in regarding
how the instance where the input is
generated
and the goal is to achieve optimal or
near Optimal Performance when the
prediction is correct while still
maintaining the best existing worst case
guarantees
um the two metric used in this framework
are called consistency and robustness
where consistency is the worst case
competitive ratio given a correct
prediction and robustness is the worst
case competitive ratio overall so it's
the center notion of the worst case
guarantee and we're gonna revisit the
consistency and the robustness notion in
the context of scheduling paper again so
don't worry if this is too abstract or
too big
now let's take a look at the problem
itself consider this very simple
scenario with only one job and two
machines and machine one takes an hour
to run the job a machine 2 takes three
hours to run the job
and of course we wanted to assign the
job uh to the machine one because it's
more efficient
now unlike the algorithm settings in
here we actually assume each of the
machine is controlled by a self-interest
agent so the immediate consequence of
that is we need to pay each of the
machine or the agent
um for the the job that they run we need
to compensate them and for example in
this case if we were to allocate the job
to the first machine we need to pay her
at least a value of one in order to
cover the cost that she needs to run the
job
um and if of course if we pay her more
she's gonna get happier so the utility
of the agent is defined to be the
compensation they receive minus the
processing time and agent whenever they
can would try to maximize this utility
on top of that we also assume instead of
knowing as mechanism knowing the
processing time of
um the
jobs we assume that these processing
time are actually private to the machine
so only the agents know the processing
time and the mechanism needs to elicit
the True Value
um before they can make any reasonable
decisions
so let's look like let's look at the
naive approach that we were saying
earlier
um you know we wanted to allocate it to
the cheapest machine and you know we can
pay the mad machine the processing time
not the report in this example we would
pay the first machine a payment of one
which uh results in a utility of zero
for the first machine however this naive
approach has some loopholes in it
um in particular
um the the machine one has the
alternative to report a processing time
of two now the machine one will still
get the job because two is still less
than three however the utility she gets
from reporting a two instead of a one
would be one instead of zero so she can
increase her utility by reporting a two
instead of a one
and in general we would want to prevent
this type of lying option for the agent
by designing strategy-proof mechanisms
so a strategy-proof mechanism is a
mechanism consists with an allocation
rule and a payment law such that no
agent can benefit from misreporting
which is this exactly the scenario if
agent One Missed reports to two she can
increase her utility and we don't want
this type of behavior to exist in a
strategy-proof mechanism
and um for this specific setting the low
line of literature of mechanism design
actually already provided us with a slow
motion called the second price auction
so the second price auction says that
you allocate the job to the cheapest
machine but instead of paying whatever
they claim we pay them the second
cheapest processing time and it's not
hard to verify that the second price
auction here is in fact truthful or
strategy proof
so
um so we let's formally Define the
general setting of strategic scheduling
problem
um this problem was first considered by
Nissan Ronin in their famous
um algorithmic mechanism design paper
that essentially started AMD and it has
been an active research area for the
past two decades
um the general setting consists of
non-related machine and M jobs and the
Machine I takes pij to run job J and I'd
like to emphasize here again that in the
Strategic scheduling setting these pijs
are private information
um and the objective is for us to find
an allocation X that minimize the make
span uh where make span is the maximum
sum of processing time of any machine
um for this specific example if we know
all of the processing time
um the minimum makes band is achieved by
assigning each of the job diagonally
um
and the minimum expand would be 1.1
um
so in a full information setting if we
know everything
um there is a two approximation on
polysam algorithm and it is still MP
hard to approximate it within a factor
of 1.5 so even if in a full information
setting we won't be able to solve it
optimally in polytime now in the
Strategic version of the problem Nissan
Roland considered the famous vcg
mechanism on this this problem but BCG
essentially is just running second price
auction
um for each of the job individually
um so for each of the job we can we are
we're going to allocate it to the
cheapest machine and pay them the second
cheapest processing time so if we run
vcg on this specific instance we will
allocate all of the jobs onto the last
machine and this in turn would result in
a processing time in a make span of five
where the optimum expand is 1.1 so we
know that
um the second price auction where the
vcg is not going to be optimal and in
fact this greedy approach could be as
bad as M Factor away from the optimum
um and Nissan Ronan in the same paper
conjecture that not only does vcg needs
to software this um bound they believe
that no truthful mechanism can achieve
an approximation better than n
and very recently Chris o'doul Edo
proved that no truthful mechanism can
achieve approximation ratio better than
one plus square root of n so even if the
conjecture is wrong the best worst case
guarantee that we can hope for is still
pretty horrible
um well I think we'd like to point out
is that though
um both the negative results and the
conjecture heavily depends on the
assumption that the mechanism has no
clue about the private processing time
which given the amount of historical
data we have like our hands nowadays and
also the advanced machine learning
techniques this assumption is a bit
unrealistic and also pessimistic
um this motivated us motivated the study
of the following problem
um that given an accurate prediction
um somewhat accurate prediction had P
about to the private processing time P
so for each of the job machine pair we
have a prediction over the actual
processing time
can we design a mechanism that takes in
both the prediction and the actual
instance
and achieve a much broader performance
without sacrificing too much of the
worst case guarantees
so
um we're gonna use the two metric that
we introduced earlier in the algorithm
design with prediction framework
um called consistency and robustness
we're the robustness takes in the worst
combination of prediction and the actual
instance notice that the prediction and
the actual instance doesn't need to be
the same so we allow the prediction to
be arbitrarily wrong
and the worst um the performance of
robustness needs to hold no matter what
the combination is and uh consistency on
the other hand measures the worst case
competitive ratio given a correct
prediction so notice here we're assuming
that the prediction and the actual
instance is identical
um now prior to our work SRI and LU in
um this year's paper considered the
exact same setting and then they
proposed a mechanism with constant
consistency and N cubed robustness in
this work we showed um we proposed a
mechanism called scaled greedy and
showed that the skilled greeting
mechanism is strategy proof three
consistent and 2N robust
um and in fact our bound is parametrized
by gamma where we achieve two plus gamma
consistent and one plus one over gamma
and robust
robustness
um so just to kind of like take another
extra 10 seconds to interpret the result
a little bit more
um we're saying if the prediction
provided to us is correct we get no more
than three times more than the optimal
makes spend and even if the prediction
is completely wrong we can still get a
small constant away from vcg which is
the best known
um worst case guarantee out there
um and
due to the time constraint I won't be
able to go through the details of our
mechanism so for the rest of the talk I
will try to deliver the key concept of
our design and hopefully provide some
useful insights and intuition about
algorithm or mechanism design with
predictions in general
um so to kind of like get the wheel
going let's focusing on the easy task
first which is guaranteeing a good
consistency
remember that to get good consistency we
just need to perform well when the
instance is exactly the same as the
predicted instance since we're given the
predicted instance we can pre-calculate
the optimal makes band allocation
um for example if we're given this
specific predicted instance we know that
the optimal schedule would be to
schedule the first machine a first job
on the first machine and the second job
on the second machine
so we know which job we should put on
which machine basically we have a
destination for each of the job
um
so note that as we showed in the
previous example this optimal machine
might not be the machine output by the
greedy allocation for example for
Machine 2 the greedy would assign the
machine to on the first uh the agree
with sign the second job on the first
machine instead of the second machine
well I think we can do though is for
each of the job we can scale up the
processing time of all of the other
machine just enough so that the optimal
machine would win even if we're wrong
greedy
so uh one thing we can do here is we can
apply a scalar of K for the second job
on the first machine
now
um the benefits of have running this
skilled greedy type of approach is that
we essentially get strategy provenance
for free
um so as long as the scalars will apply
is independent of the actual instance we
can always make the allocation rule
strategy proof by pair it with some
payment scheme
um so
again consistency only binds when the
actual instance is exactly the same as
the predicted instance so consider the
case where the actual instance is the
same as the predicted instance and we
know that if we apply a scalar on the
second job or with the first machine
um running greedy would give us
um the optimal schedule that we want so
what we could do is take the actual
instance apply the scaling that we said
earlier and and run the greedy on the
skilled actual instance which would give
us the optimal schedule that we want
which is the optimal schedule of the
actual instance
so this approach of you know
pre-calculating the optimal schedule and
scale up all of uh the processing time
of all of the other machine give us the
optimal consistency but let's take a
look at how how does the scalars affect
the robustness
um because that's also one thing we also
need to achieve now remember that the
robustness needs to hold the performance
guarantee we get for robustness needs to
hold no matter what the actual instance
is and the actual instance could look
completely different from the predicted
instance so consider
um instead the actual instance being uh
as follow where we mispredicted the
processing time of the first machine for
both of the job
um so instead of having K and one the
processing time of the first machine is
actually zero and one plus Epsilon and
now as we said earlier the scalar we
apply needs to be independent of
um the actual instance and in order to
achieve the good consistency we need to
apply this K scaler and if we apply the
case scalar on this actual instance
we're going to get a different scaled
actual instance and if we run the greedy
on this specific instance we're going to
get the same allocation as we did before
which result in a make span of K
however if you look at the actual
instance
um this specific one the optimal
schedule the optimal thing to do would
be to assign both of the job on the
first machine instead and the optimum
expand in that case would be one plus
Epsilon
and now since
um our mechanism output is K and then
the optimal make span is one plus
Epsilon and K could be arbitrarily large
we therefore show that the scaled greedy
version one
um has unbounded robustness even though
it has uh one consistency and in fact in
our paper we showed that not just the
scaled greedy any one consistent
strategy proof mechanism must suffer
this unbounded robustness so in order to
achieve any reasonable robustness one
inevitably needs to relax in terms of
consistency
and if we kind of like take a step back
and look at why we're suffering the
unbounded robustness it's probably due
to the fact that we're scaling um a lot
in um one of the machine job pairs
this
essentially were blindly following the
prediction to enforce one specific
allocation and once the prediction is
wrong we have no guarantee whatsoever
so this observation lead us to the
skilled greedy version 2. where we're
taking the initial version but adding a
cap on how much we can scale up the
processing time
so the mechanisms are again given the
prediction would calculate the optimal
schedule and try to make the optimal
machine for each job uh the cheapest
Machine by scaling up all of the
processing time of all of the other
machines
however if the scalar we need to apply
is more than n we simply apply a scalar
of n instead
um now intuitively
this version should give us a better
robustness because we're limiting the
bias we're imposing on the outcome in
other words we're kind of messing with
the instance a little bit less
um
however since not all of the jobs are
necessarily going to the optimal machine
because for some of them we might not
scale them enough
um we're definitely going to lose in
terms of consistency well the good news
is that we showed um that the jobs that
we assigned sub-optimally are actually
negligible in terms of consistency
um and in fact even if all of such jobs
ended up in the same machine they
contribute at most one extra optimal
make Span in terms of consistency
so in our warm-up session we showed that
the greedy skilled greedy version 2
um is too consistent with N squared
robustness
um and uh we have an instance to show
that the squared robustness is actually
tight
um so just to provide some like high
level intuition of how we get this
n-square robustness
um this is a compound in fact of both uh
vcg and the scalar where
um in vcg vcg has this myopic effect
where we're supposed to assign the jobs
diagonally but we ended up putting all
of them on the same machine and each of
the job on the same machine
um on top of the vcg also suffered from
this skilled up effect event so that's
how we get the n-square of robustness
so version two essentially provided us
with a way to improve robustness without
losing too much in terms of consistency
in the final version of the skilled
greedy we really exploit the idea and we
tried to bound the scalars more
aggressively and carefully
um in particular skilled greedy
essentially takes the first version and
instead of bounding the individual
scalar at n we bound the sum of the
biggest scalar of each machine at n and
we also try to avoid scaling when the
consistency constraint is not tight on
some specific machines and using these
two nice property we showed that the
scale greedy version 3 has achieved
three consistency and two earned
robustness
and um if you're interested in how we
guarantee these two nice property and
how these two nice property help us
prove the bound that we're claiming uh
so uh please check out our uh full
version of the paper for details
so besides this you know nice mechanism
that achieves asymptotically The Best of
Both Worlds guarantee in terms of
consistency and robustness we also
propose this Aero tolerated skilled
version
um of the mechanism that obtains good
guarantee even if the prediction is not
fully correct
um so if we let ETA which is the maximum
mispredicted ratio to be the error of
the prediction
given a air tolerance parameter hats air
hats at all the Aero tolerated version
of skilled greedy achieves an
approximation of three at a square if
ETA is less than or equal to
and hat at a square n otherwise
so what this is what this result mean is
that you can
pre-define uh how much error you want to
tolerate in your mechanism
um by like like toning the mechanism a
little bit differently and if the your
PR the actual error of the prediction is
within the error tolerance level that
you set you get this three at a square
um approximation ratio which is uh much
better than the robustness
um bound that we're claiming earlier and
even if your error is above this error
tolerance level you said you still get
bounded robustness and in particular if
the error tolerance level you set is
constant
um and if your actual error is within
this error tolerance you still get
constant performance and even if your
error is above this error tolerance you
get you still get linear um robustness
no matter what
so just to kind of like provide high
level consistency robustness trade-off
at high level for this specific problem
um we know that to get good consistency
we essentially need those scalars to
guide the jobs to the desired machine
however to get good robustness we need
to avoid scaling as much as possible and
in general
um for algorithm design with prediction
or mechanism would design with
prediction problems to get good
consistency we inevitably needs to
introduce some sort of bias or favor for
some specific outcome over some others
whereas to get good robustness we need
to limit in terms of how much we're
trusting the prediction and how much
bias we want to impose on these
um outcomes and designing a good
mechanism that has nice trade-off
between consistency and robustness is
essentially finding the delicate balance
in terms of how much bias you want to
impose on the outcome sent if an outcome
is like reasonable in terms of both of
the um objectives
so just to summarize the paper and also
the talk we revisit the strategy proof
machine scheduling problem with the
learning augmented framework and we
achieved three consistency with two and
robustness with the skilled greedy
allocation rule and on top of that we
also have the error tolerance version of
the mechanism that achieved good
approximation ratio even if your
prediction is not completely correct
um this result asymptotically matches
the best consistency with the best known
robustness
um and finally would like to take the
time to motivate or to like advertise
the learning augmented framework
essentially you can use the framework
and revisit any mechanism or algorithm
design question you like as we believe
this framework is really useful and
hopefully it would
um motivate us to design more practical
mechanisms in the future and that
concludes my talk thanks